oh my god let's say you're dating a guy
okay you guys are talking about the past
one time I had sex with a Thai
is that a problem
look at that face was he aware yes like
it was intentional intentional a lot of
the Thai lady boys look hotter than the
girls what did he do specifically
yeah he the butt
Milk The Cow he's willing to admit that
he enjoyed it but he wouldn't go back
but it feels like I was just very
open-minded during that time I got it
out of my system it's like when you eat
foie gras right you don't eat all the
time you just do it for special
occasions okay so it depends on how
invested I am in this person and when he
told me six months in oh no we're good
one year one year five years five years
you guys are married and then he tells
you it happens he tells you in the
middle of the vows it's Dion Dion Cole
has this experience
[Laughter]